You never give her a single dime. I hate that girl. Um, yeah.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I I'm not ex
I'm very sorry. That's a Zena shot. That's a Zena shot. That's
a Zena shot. He's taking shots of Zena. Uh-oh. When you have
This sounds like when Zena leaks, right? This is never the whole
story. This is never ever ever the whole story. Everything he's
saying here is like super slanted, and I can hear just how slanted
it is, right? I'm such a leech, but you won't catch me sucking
up to ice during these crashs because he is in the wrong. Kimmy
has done everything right and loves that man. He has no reason
to behave the way he's behaving. Sam should remember who got
him his deal at the start. That's why he still gets paid with
Viewbots.
Ooh. Ooh.
So, Kimmy and Ice Boseidon started having some big argument in
their Discord. In the Ice Boseidon Discord. Okay. The Kimmy drama
started the house party. Okay. All right. All right. All right,
dude. It's uh it's pretty crazy.
Okay. Kenny just comes in not out of nowhere but almost out of
nowhere and posts in Ice Besidons.
Okay. Check Discord. What do you mean check Discord yourself?
I'm looking at Discord. What? They're just
walking the streets at night. Why did Why am I checking Discord
in a river of darkness? Start here. Start with this.
Okay. All right. Oh, they don't want 30-year-old women. I saw
her phone. It was a Discord viewer, but I never got a pick before.
She went behind my back to send a dude pics for money like 3
weeks ago because she needed money and I got because she would
should have just asked me instead. She'll paint me as a villain.
Uh she'll paint me as a villain, but I promise you I was mentally
and emotionally abused for months and months because she made
me feel so bad about myself. Kim isn't loyal and I'm and I'm
doing a stream with Aiden mid July anyways. They don't want 30-year-old
women. Okay, bro. What are you doing?
Kimmy went to a party and Ice didn't go. One of the guys was
flirting with Kimmy and Ice got P. Okay, brother.
Ice does this sometimes with his girlfriend where he'll like
he'll say some that's pretty crazy
and it's like, "Bro,
okay. All right. They don't want 30-year-old women as at his
Aiden collab." Okay. I saw her phone, but I couldn't get a kiss.
She wanted to fly to Europe to hang with a 20-year-old 21-year-old
broke league kid. When we first broke up, she was infatuated
with a 21-year-old when she was 27. Lol. She's pathetic. Kim
is a girl who will never find happiness because she will always
want validation from everyone who shouldn't care she shouldn't
care about. All my crashes came from a real place over long periods
of time. She'll paint me as a villain, but I promise you I was
emotionally okay. Same one. Oh, I'm also reading these. These
are top. These are Bro, these are the worst. Jesus. Okay, I should
be reading them bottom up. Bottom up. Bottom up. Let me start
again. Trip behind my back to send a dude pics. Okay. Blah blah
blah blah. They don't want 30-year-old women at her ice thing.
At his ice thing. I saw her phone. They don't want 30-y old women.
And I'm doing a stream with Aiden mid July. Kim isn't loyal because
she made me feel so bad about myself. She'll paint me as a villain,
but I promise you I was mentally and emotionally abused for months.
All my crashes came from a real place over a long period of time.
Kim is a girl who will never find happiness because she will
always want validation from people she should care about. Yeah,
I know. I'm really back. I got it. I got it. I got it. When we
first broke up, she was infatuated with this 21-year-old league
kid. She wanted to fly to Europe, but I couldn't get a kiss.
The ring was 65k, by the way. She's getting another nose job.
Oh no, dude. Don't do the nose thing again. Ice, what are you
doing? Don't do the nose thing again, bro. Come on, dude.
Come on, man.
Come on, man. Don't do it again.
He So,
his girlfriend had like a apparently like a big nose or something.
I don't even know cuz she looks super attractive whenever I see
her. Okay.
But uh apparently everybody in his chat makes fun of her nose
all the time. And she got a nose job. And then he leaked here
that she's getting another nose job in October for $25,000 in
Dallas. That's everything in her bank account and will be completely
broke when she does it. I cried and begged for her not to do
it because it's a waste of money. And she called me selfish.
Bro, it was a normal nose before. Bro, I haven't seen
Can I get a comparison picture? Can we get some comparison pics?
Yeah, I I think Bro, there's like things you have in a relationship
where you should know I'm never going to leak this thing about
you cuz I know you're insecure about it. Like, if I ever leak
this thing about you, this would be like I know this would be
the end. And I'm positive I besid leaking like her her rhinoplasty
stuff is got to be like up there. That's up, dude. Uh she also
had other surgeries, but I'll keep those in my back pocket.
Dude, what the [__] are you doing? What the do you
mean? You keep those in your back pocket. What are you saying?
She also had other surgeries, but I'll keep those in my back
pocket. Yeah, that appendecttomy. Okay. Get that appendecttomy
saved for a for a rainy day. Didn't work and I paid for everything.
It's 2500 a month. That's fine. I hope so. She abused me emotionally
for so long. She doesn't live in Texas. Won't apply. Me and Kim
never had she always had a yeast infection and BV.
Uh BV. Why can't I think of what BB is?
I can't think of it off the top of my head. Where'd she get those
things from? Oh, right. That's She That's right. She blamed me
for getting BB,
but we never bacterial vaginosis. Gross. But we never had Kim
cheated on me twice as well emotionally by going on dates and
Hinge. Kim cheated. Okay. She refused to watch Snoopy when I
was in Japan. She didn't even She doesn't even like her friends.
I have text of her talking all her friends. I'll cut them off.
She will never find a rich successful guy like me. Why? Because
rich because successful men won't want to deal with the emotional
abuse and controlling nature that she has does. She's also lazy
and refuses to cook, clean, and work. Nothing. Not even. She
does nothing of value. Nothing. Yes, I'm already letting her
go. Me destroying her like this and linking all of this stuff
is me detaching. Darkness.
She hates cute bot. She hates all her friends. She has talked
on all of her friends and forced me to not include her friends
in my streams. Send me the Mike Smalls clip. The one where Mike
says she looks single or something. Funny coming from a girl
who's the only underage person at a party with alcohol. Oh, that's
a Zena shot. That's a Zena shot. That's a Zena shot. That's a
Zena shot. He's taking shots of Zena. Uh-oh.
She has no loyalty. Lol.
Tried to get her friends to me and actively brought women over
to me when I was single. Said she'd run a train on me and Joel.
A train with me and Joel. Doesn't talk to Kim unless she needs
something. Money. Oh, hold on. Is this Zena again? tried to get
her friends to me and actively brought women over to me when
I was single. She said she'd run a train on me and Joel or run
a train with me and Joel. Doesn't talk to Kim unless she needs
something. Money comes and money goes. Grooms Shuy because she's
so desperate to leech for money and cried when she lost KCIP
and was forced to strip again. Then told Kimmy she's on her side
while simultaneously bringing her friends over to me. Oof.
Why is ice
I'll be honest.
I'll be honest. Okay. And I don't want to I don't want to be
an ice boseidon. Why are none of my songs? Hello. Can this radio
run?
What is happening? Yeah, please keep playing music. What these
texts to me sound exactly like when you have this sounds like
when Zena leaks, right? This is never the whole story. This is
never ever ever the whole story. Everything he's saying here
is like super slanted and I can hear just how slanted it is,
right? That like if he was ever talking to Zena
If you was ever talking to Zen about this Yeah, Sinatra, we'll
get the part where he goes on Sam uh Sam Pepper stream here where
he calls in there. Yeah, we'll we'll go to that in a little bit.
I know. I know. Just chill.
Just chill. We'll go. We'll get there.
Okay. We will get there. I promise. Yeah. If he was talking to
Zena while saying this, there's no way he'd say these things,
right? He would totally not say these things cuz she'd be there
to be like, "No, this is what happened. This is what happened.
That's what happened." But when you are the only person in a
certain space talking, it's very easy to to sort of slant things
in your
Zena would defend behaviors from Kimmy. Zena is a used up 30-year-old
woman who has nothing going for her in life other than the fact
that she can use her extremely low tier to trick horny 19-year-old
boys or used up 29-year-old men who have also nothing going for
them. Okay. What did Darius do to you, bro? Darius literally
just helped you with your content. What the You just take a shot
of Darius out of nowhere? What the [__] are we doing
here? No, that's true. And Darius is a piece of but like not
to Ice Poseidon. Darius sucks ice. How the What did Darius do
to you, bro? Darius takes shots at ice when I'm not worried about
him me over. I'm establishing control and potentially exiled
people. If Kimmy says the right things, I'll reinstate him. Okay.
You are afraid of Ice Poseidon. What the reminder? Are we all
answer my call? Answer the phone. That orgy time. I used to know
that D big
Okay. My orgy action man can sit in the chair. Okay. I support
Kimmy no matter what. If someone has negative to say in my server,
ban them. The only respect I have for Ice is that he's my best
friend's man. I'm grateful for the opportunity he's given me.
Opportunities he's given me, but that doesn't make me anyone's
butt buddy. Yes, man. Uh but buddy, yes, man. I will always choose
loyalty over money. Money comes and goes. Real love and friendships
are not that easy to come by. I'm such a leech, but you won't
catch me sucking up to Ice during these crashs because he is
in the wrong. Kimmy has done everything right and loves that
man. He has no reason to behave the way he's behaving. I wish
he would get therapy and do better instead of going public with
their problems and regretting it later.
Uh later when he hurts her. All the leeches taking his side.
CX can suck my witchy [__] Don't scare me. My Oh,
whoops. I shouldn't have read that word. My loyalty will never
bend over viewers. Lauo Kimmy has done more for my life than
anyone in streaming might have done. That's all I got to say.
Oof. Okay, I think this is the next album here. But let me let
me make sure.
Black Irish, I don't even have a stream dock anymore. I just
got rid of it. It was not helpful.
Well, it was helpful sometimes, but it was not always helpful.
Okay, then we go to the tape deck, I think. Then we go to the
tape deck thing. Or do we go after? I think we go No, no, no.
We go here next. We go here next. He would call me.
Sam should remember who got him his deal at the start. That's
why he still gets paid with Viewbots.
Paul, you've got to you've got to you've got to you can't you've
got to move. I don't want to talk I don't want to talk to you
on the phone about Kimberly. Okay. Everything I'm going to say
was already in Discord. But I will talk about Cena. Cena is an
absolute
She's 30 years old. Has nothing going for her except basically
underage person who can't even drink at the party that they're
at. She has nothing going for her. The moment she's done with
Sam was talking about Aena first, which is why ICE sent that
message streaming. She's when she had no KCIP for burning the
Quran, which I don't even know why they gave that back to her
when she lost her KCIP for doing that. She had to go back to
being a stripper at the uh She didn't burn the Quran. You were
stripped of town. And guess what? You know who got her? Hold
on. Zena called in before
Okay, these were the messages. Is this Oh, Jesus Christ. Just
want to crash out and say, but here we go. Respectfully, I just
hope he gets the help you need. Okay, I know Kim is your friend,
but I think you need to admit at least that they just shouldn't
be together, right? No, she called after. Well, she called before,
too. Um, I think if he's going to continue to put guns to his
head that Yeah, he needs he needs to get help. No, but I think
also Kim's toxic for Ice, too. I don't think she's doing anything
wrong. I think she's done a lot of self-growth and she's putting
in the work to make the relationship work and actually fix the
issues that needs to be fixed. And she's made it to the goalpost
and I think she's just twiddling his and he needs to start making
the steps to to get there. That's what he needs to do. And he
needs to get help because I think all this like stream stuff
maybe blew in his head. I don't know. But I mean, not having
with someone, not having sex with someone for 4 months and not
kissing someone is How do you know if that's even true, honestly?
Like, honestly, we're not in their relationship. We don't know
what's I mean, Zena Zena, would you ever post online? Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. How do you know that's true? I know. We all know exactly
what Sam's going to say. Ain't no guy going to say, "My girlfriend
won't me unless his girlfriend's actually not him." Okay. That's
not something you're proud of. That's not something you're getting
out there because you want to brag about it. That's something
where you're like at the end of your rope and you're like, I
don't know what to do anymore. She will me, man. She will me.
That's like that's where your mind's at if you're saying that.
Okay. It's not like ah, my girlfriend hasn't me in 4 months.
What now? That's not how anybody says that, right? He's literally
having a breakdown. I as a you know like as a guy you've got
to imagine as a guy as eyes do you know how humiliating that
is to say that your girlfriend that you like I understand right
now I don't think that he even cares about anything that's coming
out his mouth the only thing he cares about is Kimmy right now
and he wants Kimmy in front of him visibly physically in front
of him he will say anything and everything to make it look bad
and to make her feel guilt so that she is there I don't think
he cares what's coming out his mouth I don't even think he's
serious about half the he's saying I think he's just saying whatever
because he's manic That's it.
It's embarrassing. Stealing my bit. Here's one thing. He's stealing
my bit. These crash outs are my thing. That's me. I'm supposed
to be posting knives to my throat and being like, "You did this.
Keep in." So, bro, Zena just rolled this
Ice is having a mental breakdown. He's having his own like uh
he's having his own moment. Okay. Ice Poseidon is having his
own episode right now. Okay. He's talking about 30-year-old women.
He is just projecting right now. He realizes he's over the hill
for the kind of content he does and and he's just projecting
all over the place. Okay, I'm just saying like he's having a
fullon Zena the witch crash out at this point. And that's why
I'm like, bro, this ain't serious. He just he just needs to calm
I I mean I think a lot of the things he's saying are so embarrassing.
They can't be they can't be like lies. And I think that it's
Sam, if we're going to be honest, if we're going to be honest,
I mean, I don't think you necessarily get to talk about what's
embarrassing or not. You your entire existence is also embarrassing.
Like, so I don't know why you're making commentary on this in
the first place.
You're not a good friend to him at all. You don't give him good
advice. You're a horrible person. And you know, I think the best
advice is that they need to separate. Obviously, when you're
in a relationship, you probably want him single so I can
try to do work. Yes.
Okay. Let me ask you something about your past, Cena. Have you
ever been in a relationship that's worked out where you've broken
up with the person? No. Where you've broken up with the person
10 times?
Like I think at that point there's no way you can be together.
You know that. Obviously, it's not a healthy if you've broken
up with someone 10 times. It there's it's not working
10 times.
Okay. So, are you going to call your daddy eyes beside him and
tell him that maybe he shouldn't be with Kimmy because his mental
isn't right? Is that what you're going to do or are you just
going to keep streaming and calling people to get more clips
so you could talk about a relationship that you wish you were
in? No, I te I already text him and I already told him that he
needs to run away from that and never return. I'm sure he's going
to listen to your advice cuz I'm sure you give the best and sound
advice on relationships and women. Sam, how I mean that's my
that's my opinion. That's my opinion. You know, I I genuinely
Zena Zena won't stop taking shots right now. Leave these guys
alone. I don't think any What did Sam Pepper do to you, Zena?
Everybody needs to base their relationships off some other random
person's opinion. That's the issue right now. these chatters,
you these parasocials, you your opinion does not matter. Their
opinions and what they want to do with their relationship is
what matters. I'll give my advice and if I'm going to tell my
this [__] sitting in a car with a gun to his head
of He's sitting in a car.
Wait, did he actually say that? Is that actually something he
said that like I have a gun to my head in this car right now?
Cuz I didn't see that message in all the messages. I didn't see
that one. If picker keep continues, I'll just go live at the
same time and do my own version. That's mature. That she humiliated
me and ruined my self-confidence. I will make sure she suffers.
Kim chose Hannah and Leeches who need me to survive over me.
Her boyfriend of 8 years who did literally everything for her.
She will realize how tough it is. Oh, here we go. Here we go.
Here was like all the messages and delete anything. Blah blah
blah blah blah. Hannah will die alone. I'm just going to blacklist
everyone associated with Hannah and friends with Kimmy. Yeah,
they'll choose me.
base. Uh, base Ghost is a good mod, but I can't have him mod
if it's over. Last time we broke up, he leaked my text to her,
and when he had my Gmail, and I didn't know. I have equity in
a slot provider. I'm good. Where's this whole thing about the
gun? I don't even see the gun thing.
Last time someone me off with Kimmy, they had their their [__]
at $1 for a minute. Lol.
Fortunately, Shuy is a part of that group, considering he's dating
Zena. If Kicker Keep continues, I'll go live and do my own version.
I made these people. They need to remember the power I hold in
this scene. Oh, this is embarrassing. Oh, this is actually more
embarrassing than I thought. Oh, it's actually way more
Oh boy. Oh boy.
Blocker then don't associate. You have to choose between me and
your career or your girlfriends. Sorry to put you in this position.
Oh, this is the Shuy text that we saw later on, right? This is
one of these.
I do not claim her, sir. Block her then and don't associate.
That's this one, bro. That's up, dude. Oh, by the way, uh if
you guys are in the Discord, I just remembered we have a new
tag for the Discord. So, you can opt into this new tag. This
new tag is like uh it's actually got the JSTLK in it now. Okay,
so opt into the new tag.
That's what we're looking for. Oh, right. I saw I have this one
somewhere in like something. Uh allegedly, I beside threats because
his girlfriend Kim would have with him. Uh, do you like this?
Do you want me to [__] myself because you really
make me want to do it? Paul, I'm in love with you. I would never
want that. Please stop.
Hard to not be insecure. Me and Kim have only had one time in
four months. Uh,
bruh. Bruh,
bruh. Bruh, you got to stop. You got to stop. You must stop.
Stop now. The gun to his head.
Why is he smiling? Cuz I think when he put when he took that
picture, he was not talking about himself. He definitely like
took that picture at a totally different time. You're not going
to make it. You're not their nobody's goddamn relationship guru.
You're a dumb ass British twink who the can't even go back to
his own country or America. Stick your ass in Thailand. Keep
paying Peggy to love you cuz nobody else. Bro, I'm always going
to the UK. What do you mean? I'm always going to the UK. Zena,
he has a gun to his head in his car. Obviously, they shouldn't
be together, right? Obviously,
she's gone, bro. that it's like how can you how can you sit there
and say they're meant to be together? That's crazy.
That's crazy.
There's no way you can sit there and say they're meant to be
together. Okay, hold on.
Okay, we can close this one. I'm going to get to a couple of
these other ones. Wait, where did I put the big collage here?
There it is. There it is. Kim has until midnight to show up,
but I don't see her showing up. So, he's just like blackmailing
her, I guess. Right. Here's the shuvie part was up here. You
won't have any opportunity on Kick. Without me, none of these
people have an opportunity on Kick. There wouldn't be a Kick
IRL community without me. Yeah, I know. But that's okay. I need
everyone to know what to do and what not to do, so it's clear.
Everyone knows everything about me. I don't need to use dating
apps, lol. Girls message me all the time. I just always block
them all immediately.
Yes, no one can say anything. That's new. But the secrets I hold
are pretty insane. Okay, well, I'm going to ban Zena until she's
she communicates Kim and Hana. Till she excommunicates, I guess.
Anthony better pay me back 3500. He has 30 days. It's the principal.
I would never want to hang and around with low-v valueue women.
Kim has until midnight to show up, but I don't see her showing
up. If she doesn't show up, I'll give some of her dirty secrets.
That she humiliated me and ruined my self-confidence. I will
make sure she suffers. She's emotionally abused me for far too
long. And now she will know how it feels. Zena is anything. I'll
make sure she gets banned on kick. Remember when she tweaked
twerked on the Quran? Guess who's Muslim? the mods. Kim chose
Hannah and leeches who need me to survive over me. Her boyfriend
of 8 years. We read that one. She went behind my back to send
a dude pics for like for money like 3 weeks ago. We read through
these ones, right? Basically all of these ones. Yeah. So, we
got up to She has other surgeries, but I'll keep those in my
back pocket. Yeah. Yeah. Nicky, I'm picking that up. Yeah, I'm
picking that up. Ice Boseidon being a real Ethan Klein. Listen,
guys, it's the principal, okay? He's just trying to protect the
kick IRL community by leaking that his girlfriend's having another
rhinoplasty, right? He's doing that for you guys, okay? Because
he's trying to make sure this ecosystem, this kick IRL ecosystem
survives. That's why he has to leak that his girlfriend's having
another nose job in October in Dallas. If he didn't care about
the kick IRL community, he would never leak that. All right,
cuz he is a hero. A true hero. I said he's going to pay me 50%
of the revenue of his second month in the 24/7 Japan subathon.
He just didn't. He apologized when he got back and I forgave
him and let it slide without getting mad at him for even a second.
That was like 25k plus. And I didn't press him over it because
I knew he needed the money during that time more than me. Then
Kick came later and he's a millionaire pressing me for 3.5K.
I can't. So Anthony says he's not paying ice, I guess. All right,
this is back to when Ice Boseidon does actually call in to San
Pepper stream for her.
Okay, Paul, you've got to I would call me in this situation.
I've got to be real. I've got to be real with myself. Ice would
call me in this situation for the for the intel. He would. And
I just would tell it to off if I wanted him off. He Okay, so
Sam Oh, Sam makes the call to him. Oh,
for the content. Real Lauren de Lagona type of guy. This Sam
Pepper guy. You guys remember Lauren de Laguna was like, "Hey,
Hunter Avalone. I know you just got shot at. I know your girlfriend's
literally still bleeding, but can I get that exclusive first
interview?" That's Sam Pepper right now. Except that's always
been Sam Pepper. Sam Pepper is more that guy.
Have you seen the clip of Anthony talking about him getting laid?
No. Link it. Link it. Link it. Right now. Paul, you've got to
you've got to you've got to you can't you've got to move. I don't
want to talk I don't want to talk to you on the phone about Kimberly.
Okay. Everything I'm going to say was already in Discord. But
I will talk about Zena. Zena is an absolute
She's 30 years old. Has nothing going for her except basically
underage person who can't even drink at the party that they're
at. She has nothing going for her. The moment she's done with
streaming, she's when she had no KCIP for burning the Quran,
which I don't even know why they gave
Okay, link me the Cubs Kimmy clip then. Link me these clips.
Don't ask me if I've seen the clip. Just link the clip, bro.
Link the clip where she lost her KCIP for doing that. I've not
seen any of the clips of being a stripper at the nearest strip
club in town. And guess what? You know who got her that job?
Me. I know the owner of the strip club. I got her the stripping
job. So, that's how you know she's completely without KCIP or
streaming or this community or anything. So, she has no leg to
stand on whatsoever.
Um, she wants to defend the behaviors. Sam Pepper just sits here
streaming. Listen,
West and Sam Pepper,
brothers, okay? Spiritual twins, all right? They're both hanging
out in these Southeast Asian countries, okay? of Kimberly that
were bad. Uh that's not a true friend. That's a really friend.
And um you know, yeah, Zena's uh I mean everything she said I
mean ZMA's too Zena's obviously two-faced, bro. She's always
playing one side hella hard for no reason.
Always. Yeah. I Zena is will never say the real opinion. She'll
only say what she thinks will benefit her the most. The only
reason she's offending Kimberly is because she's like, "Well,
you know, they're all going to they're going to patch things
up and everything will be good." Well, also, if Kimmy if Kimmy
fixes things with you, then she always stays close to you because
she uses Kimmy as the way to stay close to you, obviously.
Yeah. Did Did Zena talk that much about him? I'm trying to think
what Zena said. Zena didn't mock him for like not getting laid,
did she? Zena was just like he's having a crash out. He's having
like a Zena the Witch crash out. If you get that pressed over
somebody going like, "Oh man, he's crashing out like I crash
out." If you get that pressed over that, I don't know. You might
be a really like a hyper sensitive person. I feel like Zena did
not talk that much. She just said, "Oh, Kimmyy's my friend more
than Ice. I love I love Ice, but um but I roll Kimmy." That's
like all she said, right? That's all she said. And now Ice is
like super a mad that Zena just said the truth. She basically
said this has happened before and he'll get over it. Okay. Well,
GG. Yes, exactly. Ice is just a sociopath. What do you mean he's
a sociopath? He's literally losing his mind right now. It doesn't
seem like somebody detached from his emotions right now at all.
Okay. So, the moment
there's no Kimberly or the moment Kimberly doesn't stream anymore.
Zena is going to move on someone else. So, I we everybody in
the world sees this except for Kimberly.
Everybody sees it. It's obvious. Zena seems pretty loyal to people
who are nice to her. Well, h for the most part.
And uh you know what, Sam? I've been around Hannah a lot and
I hate her. You don't have to you don't have to explain it to
me. Who is Hannah? I don't even know who Hannah is. Who is Hannah?
Oh, I like I really hope I really hope you never give her a single
dime. I hate that girl. Um Yeah. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I I'm
not I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm very sorry.
You know, Hannah did everything in her power to bring down everybody
else around them who have, you know, things going for them because
she's an old, bitter, jealous woman.
Yes. Yes. Bad. Everything's very bad. Hold on. Hold on. Hold
on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold
on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Are you holding on?
Yeah. No, I don't. Stop. God,
I'm gonna lose it. I'm having some very annoying. I tried to
pull up this Instagram. I have to shut off my my VPN for a second
and my VPN is being annoying. This is Hannah. I don't I don't
know who this person is. I've never seen them before. I've seen
this girl on a stream before, the brunette girl, but I I don't
know who this girl is. Is that actually Sam's ex-wife? Damn.
Okay. Okay. Bad in that situation. You can't get back with Kim
Paul. You can't, bro. It's going to be so bad for you. It's so
toxic, bro. It's so toxic beyond
It's so toxic. You're like rich. You're successful.
You're at the peak of your career. Like, you have e You have
all everything, Paul. Everything. You have everything right now.
Like, this is that moment you've worked all this time for. You
can't, bro. You're just going to be miserable. I'm sure Ice Boseidon
is uh emotionally mature enough to make like an emotional connection
with another person.
You can't It's bad, bro. It's so bad. It's so bad at this point.
You know, it is. You You wrote it all out. This drama was at
Hannah's birthday or was about Hannah's birthday. Discord. You
wrote everything in Discord cuz you know you needed to write
it so that you know you know you shouldn't go back. Well, I mean
uh you know Yeah, you're right. It's It's really bad. I don't
know how it could I don't I don't know how it could possibly
uh fix itself. But um yeah, regardless of who's right or who's
wrong or who's telling this, who who's telling that or the fact
that Kim me off or anything
for both of you, for Kim and for you, it makes no sense.
It doesn't. The relationship, you know, I I don't know if it
can work. You know, you're right about that. It's really bad.
Um the fact that she
didn't defend me yesterday when I was feeling uncomfortable and
upset
is uh huge, you know, hugely eye opening to me. You know, she
had every excuse in the book, every single just so many different
excuses on the why she just couldn't defend me. So, you know,
it's very eye opening. Defend him from what? What did what did
she not defend him from? And you know, I have no idea. though.
Uh I mean even if you're being the combined especially with the
combined everything else the you know the the stuff Sam Sam knows
this is Sam's face here is like uh he knows he's doing his job.
He knows he's getting content. He knows that in his heart of
hearts Ice Boseidon can't be that mad at him. But he also knows
that Ice is going to hold this against him. Right? Ice is going
to be like why did you call me? Why did you call me when I was
losing it? Okay. Sam's standing here and he like he he's it's
bittersweet because he's getting the content, but he also knows
like this is gonna
gonna be up later that if Ice doesn't if if this doesn't end
now and it like ends a little bit later, Ice is going to get
really mad at Sam for like making this whole thing that she's
done to make me feel so insecure over the, you know, over the
course of like, you know, six, seven months just constant belittling,
constantly putting me down, constant constantly no affection,
no intimate See, I mean, and then not refusing to defend me over
anybody, especially, you know, weirdo drunk dudes, you know?
It's it's very eye opening and um it's really
and Sam don't even like each other. I thought they were like
best friends.
What do you mean? Are they not like best friends? The are we
talking about? Yeah. No, Harmony 6, I know that that's true,
but I think uh I think this is I think Ice is having like a legitimate
Okay. legitimate moment here. So, you know, uh I don't know.
You know, it's just it's really hard though because we've dated
for 8 years. It's not something that you can just walk away from.
It's a very hard thing. You know, we I put a lot of time, energy,
effort into this person. Oh, no. So, I know. I know. I know.
And also, like I've I was I've been in a really toxic relationship
kind of very similar to this and it was for like 4 and 1/2 years.
And I felt that like if if I broke up with them, you know, there's
like this saying like better the devil. Do you want Ice and Kim
to stay together just because Zena said so? No. I just I just
know that Ice besides losing his mind in a way that like I can
immediately go, "Oh, this guy's like this guy's on a uh this
guy's having like a little his own little episode right now."
Okay, he's kind of like losing it. That's what's happening right
now with Ice Boseidon. His girlfriend did not seem to be losing
it anywhere near as bad as he was. Okay. Like literally, he is
having what what most incelss here, most of the incel people,
black pill, scuba fiend, you guys, if a woman was having the
same episode that Ice Poseidon's having, you would go, "Oh, this
stupid egg hit the wall. Kick her to the curb. Get her the out
of here. Holy [__] she's losing it." Okay, woman
moment. Woman moment.
That's what you would all be saying right now. Okay, that's what
you would all be saying if this if this were a different gender
of person. Okay, but because it's Ice beside and you guys want
to take his side, shut the up. Analyze it normally. Okay, bro.
Ice is a millionaire. Okay. Yes, he is like a skitso BPD girl
billionaire. Sure. And what you would say are all these things.
Okay. Where you like just have to basically label somebody as
soon as they're having a bad moment. You know, you just label
them immediately. Yeah. That's Ice Pesidon's doing all of these
things. By the way, I don't use that language. I don't think
that way. You guys do, though. It's just weird when you won't
apply it to this guy when he's clearly losing his mind. Okay.
Devil we know and the devil you don't. It's like it's you know
all the problems with your relationship and it's scary to like
think about moving on or working some house out and you've like
you've gone through all this time with. I know that and I know
that that fear of leaving something that you've worked so hard
on. But I'm telling you like you'll find someone who works better
with you and you'll look back at that relationship and you'll
be like what the was I doing? I'm telling you 100% you will because
it it it
just you know it doesn't make sense. You've written it all out.
All you have to do is read back your chat logs. You written everything
out, Ice, you know it's beyond if that was me. Imag read back
what you've written and imagine it was me writing it. You would
tell Hold on. All of that is just one side of a story. My girlfriend
won't me for 4 months. Yeah, that sucks, dude. But I don't have
her side of the story. I don't know why she won't you. She might
have a really good reason for not wanting to you. I don't know
what it is. None of the none of the stuff Ice wrote out is like
actually any amount of like understanding a relationship. It's
just his like victimization mode for all of the issues they have,
right? He's just he's framing himself as a victim. That you cannot
understand somebody's relationship from when they have a meltdown
and vent to you about their relationship. You will never ever
ever get a good idea of what their relationship is like. Why
is Sam pretending that's the case? Because he's farming. Tell
me, what the are you doing? You would, but the only reason you're
not is cuz you're emotionally attached. Yeah, I know. It's uh
it's I would tell any of my friends to get out of the relationship.
It's uh it's it's hard. Um because, you know, at the end of the
day, she's not a bad person.
She's just a bad girlfriend.
So, it's
it's, you know, cuz, you know, we'll have plenty of times where
we're,
you know, having fun, everything's good, but the moment I need
her to step up and be a girlfriend, she fails every time. And
that's that's, you know, that's what makes it hard cuz it's not
like every day come.
If your girlfriend don't you, just dump her and move on to a
new
that sounds like the most uh what would you call it? Like emotionally
broken way of coping with the world. You you basically get into
relationships, you somebody and then as soon as they stop, you're
just like, "Oh, well, you're useless, brother.
Just get a flashlight.
Just get a flashlight, bro. That's all you got to do." She's
like
like abusing me or something, you know? It's not like that. And
it's just she fails miserably at every single thing
that she needs to not fail at. Yeah.
Oh god. All right. I mean, I don't envy your position right now.
And to be honest, I don't even think she really cares about what
I'm saying at all. Like, you know what I mean? I mean, also,
you're in this ribbon right now, Paul, where it just happens.
It fights. You explain how upset you are, and then you take her
back. So it's like, you know, I mean, it's like a dog, bro. It's
like you you you shout at the dog like bad dog and then the dog
comes and sits on your lap and you start stroking it straight
away. Like the dog's never really going to understand that it's
been a bad dog, you know? I
Uh-huh.
You can see why Sam Pepper spent a lot of his times in countries
where they don't speak English very well. Okay, this is how he
thinks about relationships. She knows. She knows that like in
a week like she's all she wrote it. She wrote it in your Discord.
I'm screenshotting all of you in sales messages because in a
week when everything's back to normal, you guys are going to
be back on my ass again or some like she already knows that it's
going to be back to normal. She's already she's already she knows
that. So there's no accountability for anything she does. That's
the problem. And that's why that's
I don't know why she I don't know why she wrote that and it's
really you know weird and confusing for me because uh she threatens
to break up with me every day that we fight and um you know she
keeps telling me even today she I mean she's keeping you in your
place. That's why she says that she's breaking up with you cuz
she's keeping you in your place
cuz it makes you insecure and it and and when you get insecure,
it makes you do like crazy things to try and like fix the relationship.
It's like basic
It's hard. It doesn't work out for her. It doesn't work out though.
So, I don't It's why it's confusing cuz every time she makes
me feel really insecure, I just crash out on stream or whatever.
Do drugs and streaming keep you from mentally aging?
No, but like realistically it's probably something, especially
for the early IRL streamers, you probably need to have some kind
of personality disorder to do that, right? Like realistically,
you probably had to be kind of up to be Ice Poseidon.
And that's not even to say that he's like totally up, but he
you probably need to have some kind of like disorder to be Ice
Beside in the first place, right? To be the guy who's going to
like stream all of his [__] 24/7.
Like I I don't even necessarily from what I've heard I don't
even think he's like that [__] up. He doesn't seem
like an awful human being. That's not what I mean. I just mean
like to to start with IRL streaming to be like the first one
to really take off with it and to like put all of your out there
and always farm relationship drama. I think you probably had
to be um there probably had to be something going on. And then
it it makes her look bad. So that's what's confusing. Yeah. But
it's still it's still control. Yeah. It's still control and it
and it and it always ends up with you two just getting straight
back together again and and and that's why it's hard cuz then
nothing gets fixed, whatever. I mean, I don't know. I think it
it's been that point right now where it's it's it's too many
times. It's too many times. I don't really know. I don't really
know where you can go from here. It's too many times. Yeah. I
don't know. I mean, I think uh you know, if we have a conversation,
I think the only
thing
that could possibly be left and but I don't even think it would
work. But the only thing that could possibly be left is if I
take complete and utter full control of the relationship and
she's not allowed to do anything that she was doing before. She's
not allowed to go to parties. She's not allowed to talk to defend
other dudes. You're not allowed to be friends with Zena. I have
to take full control of the relationship. in its entirety. You
have to have sex with me. You don't then I'll break up with you.
You have to like we you know honestly Ice just go and meet up
with Sam in the Philippines and Filipino prostitutes.
It's so easy. That's all you got to do. If you want a white girl
who is like 25 plus who like has any amount of brains, I'm sorry.
You're going to have to treat them like a human being. That's
unfortunately right. I don't know why I said white. If you want
like a you want any girl who's born in America who's like 25
plus who has any amount of intelligence, you're going to have
to treat them like a person. That's just how it is, bro. Unfortunately,
that's like where the bar is, right? That's where the bar is.
You have to treat them like a human being. Why' you say white?
Well, cuz I meant like North American, but I just I just said
white for whatever reason. Cuz his girlfriend's white, basically.
I just assume he's into white girls. He's Italian, so he wants
them white. Well, I'm just telling you that's what his girlfriend
is. Uh, but yeah, you want these. Is he turning 30? Is that the
issue? He's got to be way older than 30, right?
Ice Poseidon
age. Oh, he's only 30,
bro. I thought he was way I thought he was like 35, 40.
Holy [__] He is way younger than I thought he was.
Holy [__] I went four months. I didn't bring it up
a single time and it just never happened. So, it's like, yeah,
you have to, you know, but this it's not going to work though.
You know what I mean? That's the That's crazy, Paul. Of course,
it's not going to work cuz that's insane.
You might as well just have hire a prostitute, bro, to play girlfriend
for you. It'll be way cheaper and way less work. I mean, I say
it, then Sam says it. Okay. Yeah. Just buy if that's what you
want. If you just want to get laid, you don't want to deal with
any of the emotionality. Yes. Just pay prostitutes.
That's all you got to do, bro. If that's what you want, just
get a prostitute. Literally, just hire someone to play girlfriend
for you and live in the house. It will be cheaper. She'll offer
you more affection. She'll do everything you say. It will be
you. You give Kim everything.
Like, bro, I You know, you take the out of suspenders.
You do. I know you do and you said it. But right now, Suspenders
is getting more out of his relationship than what you get with
Kim.
That's when you need to think, "What the am I doing?" That That's
crazy, bro.
I don't lose all my I'm not losing all my money at least. I mean,
bro, but still, you know, she gets it nice. She gets it nice.
She w I see how she walks around, bro. She walks around like
she's the that she's married to like a billionaire CEO,
like a trophy wife, but like she doesn't give you the wife part.
That's Oh, I know. Then that's that's why I said, "Okay, last
stitched up. I take full control. You want to be a trophy wife,
you're going to do trophy wife stuff. And if you don't, then
whatever." I, you know, I already told her and I already texted
her yesterday. I was like I was like if you don't want to me
just let me other people if you let me other people I'm I'll
never bother you about this again and then she was like go do
it but she said it in a way where
I knows exactly what that I know exactly what that conversation
is going to be okay you can go [__] other people
but I get to do that too yeah I don't want to [__]
you but if you want to go [__] other people you don't
want to work on this and make it so that we have like some amount
of uh relationship again then I'm going to go [__]
other people too and Then immediately that is like a no-go for
him, right? If you do it, she's going to be mad. Yeah. Yeah.
But that's not what I That's not what I wanted her to say. I
wanted her to say, "Oh, no. You know, I I'm sorry that you feel
like that."
And she knows that. She knows that. That's why she didn't say
it, though. You know, that's why she said it. I was taken back.
I was taken back by that. I was like, "Okay, for you to not even
fight this and you're just like, "Whatever, go do it." Like you
really don't give a about my feelings. You really don't care
at all. You're saying everything. You are saying it, Paul. Not
me. I'm not. You're convincing me that she's not good for you.
So, what are you doing? Do you know what I'm saying? You're saying
it. Yeah. I don't know. You You're saying it in your Discord.
You're writing in the messages. You're saying it on the phone.
You know, you do know, but it again, it's it's logic verse emotions.
And you're you're letting your emotions control your your thought
process. That's the problem.
Okay. These messages must be from after the call, right? I think
these are Yeah, these are definitely after the call. Okay. Okay.
Yeah. I mean, you know, it's been 8 years. That's a long time.
It's It's uh we're so ready to go. I don't want to date. I don't
like I don't want to date other people. It's annoying. I hate
dating. I hate the I hate In the call, Ice was driving to the
airport. Okay. In the call, Ice was driving to the airport. In
the call. Okay. I hate that. I just, you know, it's annoying.
Those messages start the whole thing, I'm pretty sure. Really?
Are you sure? These might have started them. Oh, these do start
them. Oh, damn it. I didn't look at the timestamps. Some of these
I just want to read some of these off cuz they were said earlier
and it's got Kimmy actually saying something. This is embarrassing.
I'm almost a 30-year-old woman and I'm fighting in a Discord.
Anyone wondering, you're all better than me. Thank God I am your
entertainment and this isn't your life. I am a loser. Genuinely,
this is embarrassing and stupid. And at least you can enjoy laughing
at me. Okay. All right. Of course, I'm insecure. My girlfriend
not only doesn't touch me, but she actively denies me. Uh, how
about instead of fight instead of fight him uh fight him back,
you show him some love for once. She doesn't even know how to
show me love. Bro, I I Okay. Nothing. Nothing. Nothing. Kimmy
broke up with me two days ago, y'all. And you know why? Because
I complained that I had to drive one hour in traffic to pick
her up. Okay,
this this
can't be the whole fight. This is like some this is some [__]
that like you guys have had this argument like a 100 times. Nobody
ever breaks up because the first time you have an argument about
driving somewhere and it's like kind of inconvenient and you
point it out to your girlfriend, nobody's ever broken up about
that, right? This is like consistently when Ice feels inconven.
It's like somehow when Ice feels inconvenenced by his girlfriend
like, "Hey, you could just get an Uber and he doesn't want to
do something," he says like, "Hey, it's really up that you're
making me drive all this way and he complains about it until
she feels like she's not valuable enough to him for him to go
out of his way to do something for her." Right? That's like the
dynamic that's happening there. But it's so annoying when I have
to when I have to read that in from like, "Oh, she just broke
up with me cuz I did I complained once about picking her up in
traffic." Like, no, I don't think so. I'm pretty sure we all
know that's not how that went down. T I got to touch Kimberly
tonight. More than I've touched her in four years. Four months.
Sorry. Four months. Okay, hold on. Do we get Do we get some clips
to the stream stream chat here? Do we get clips in? Clips in.
Clips in. We did get clips in. Hold on. We got some clips. We
got some clips. We got some clips. What are these clips? What
are these clips? Hold on. These are clips from the Hannah birthday
party.
Give you
this is incriminating. Taylor, what is
Uh, okay. It's like a
So, she touches this guy and I says, "That's uh Is this Tanner?"
Yeah, this is Tanner. Got more touches than uh than he gets.
Yikes.
So he beat who invented horse [__] Wait, is this
this isn't Kimmy, is it? Oh, is it? What is he saying? What does
he mean? Like he's saying you look like you don't have Oh, it
is. What the h somehow that doesn't look like the same girl I
I'm trying to get her to open up. She Jimmy is in here. No, Hannah's
Nobody's in there. That's my room. Nobody's in there. Okay. Okay.
All right. I don't understand why Ice Pesign's getting like jealous
of these guys. But you don't have you don't you don't have to
date someone else. You know that, right? Right now, you don't
have to date someone else. You can just be you. Yeah, but Sam,
I want Hold on, hold on, hold on. We're not done with these yet.
Tana got to touch Kimberly tonight. More than I've touched her
in 4 months. I just want to have like a normal relationship.
You ruined Hannah's bday. Hard to not be insecure. Me and Kim
have only had sex one time in 4 months. Of course, I'm insecure.
My girlfriend not only doesn't touch me, she actively denies
me. And when we do have, it's very transactional. Unloving cold.
Uh, nothing. I just waited. But it's like we haven't had in months.
Every time I try, it's just why do you always want to have only
in 4 months? She didn't. Dude, this actually sucks so badly when
when things get to this point. Don't worry, she has sent me a
few ring options worth 40k each. I asked her to move in with
me again. She said no. She likes her apartment because it's by
the beach. She didn't even pick me over the beach. Kimmy probably
does cheat on me. She didn't pick me ever. I picked you by the
way. Keep crying. Stay poor divorced woman. Hannah, you're fake
as and I don't even like you. Lol. You better apologize to her
and you'll never make or you'll never make it on here. I'll promise
that. Very disrespectful. Hope you enjoy your one a dollar an
hour KCIP for life. You're a [__] weirdo. You tried
to get on top of her buddy. I went the wrong way again. He's
drunk who tried to cross a boundary. You tried to get on top
of her buddy. You're a [__] weirdo. Very disrespectful.
Hope you okay. This is the way it went. Keep crying. Stay poor
divorced woman was Hannah.
That's in Cubra's stream. Okay, got it. That's one one time since
April. I'm asking for anything. Last message from Kim before
she left the Discord. This is cringe. I'm out.
And then this was the nose job ship. What did she even do then?
Nothing. Not even. She does nothing of value. Goodbye. The fact
you let Malik when I told you not to and you said don't worry,
I hate you. Downloading Hinge again right now. I love you. Oh,
this is uh the fact that you let Mal What did Malik do? What
did Malik do? Behind my back to send a dup. Yeah. Yeah, we watched
all this. Oh, right here. Then disregard when I tell them. Don't
let Malik or Jaw in. You're so cringe. You hurt my feelings so
much. You don't even care. Don't let Malik or Jaw in. Tell me
you see that. Reply. No Malik or Jaw.
What the did John Oh my god. What did John do to this guy? Is
this
What the Bro, what what is happening? Are these Are these 100%
real texts? There's no way this is 100% real, is it? Why is he
trying to block those people out of the party? Is this like the
power? By the way, is this the power that we're hearing about?
I have so much power in this industry. Those are Kimmy texts
to ice.
Wait, really?
Oh, she doesn't like cute. I see.
I see. Downloading Hinge again right now. So, he let Malik into
a party. Doesn't seem like he let Jaw in. Curious. Those Those
are texts from Kimmy to blacklist him from an event. Oh boy.
Not a good look. I thought this was him. Not a good look from
the other direction. Wait, why was why why was she partying with
Malik after that then? If she hates Malik.
that Kimmy is jealous of Malik. Okay.
What the
She trying to She's all year. I would I would have known. I've
only done it once this year. It's not just a diversion. She's
right. And I've been too nice. You owed me. You owed me 3500
for two years to Anthony. Last year we had less than 10 times.
Brother, stop.
Why is he leaking these things? Why is he saying this?
Stop oversharing, dude. There's a clip of Ice saying Malik tried
to him on Ker keeper kick. Oh well, unlucky. Sounds like Ice
is a loyal guy then. He's getting laid less than 10 times and
he's turning down a bunch of different streamers. Okay. Damn.
Me and Kim never shows us a yeast infection vaginosis. Yes, I'm
already letting her go. Me destroying her like this and all this
stuff is me detaching. We read this all the Zena stuff. Okay,
we got through everything. We got through it all. We can finally
get back to the family before you know by the time I'm 35. Now,
oh, did Kimmy Kimmy lived in that house with Cupbot and Malik
and Jaw?
I see. Well, that makes it totally different a little bit, doesn't
it? I feel like that might make it almost entirely different.
Okay, if she lived in that house, then her hating those people
could be not based on like some insecurity. It could literally
just be that like we had really up roommate experiences,
you know what I mean? How old are you? I'm 30. You have 5 years,
bro. That's like pretty much the same. Wait, is this another
Is this another random Filipino woman without her pants on in
Sam's apartment? Or is this the same one? Cuz she seems to be
another one that just walked in without her pants on in Sam's
apartment. Okay, this guy is living his best whoring it up. Time
you and Kim have been together.
Uh, we
thought she went off screen to the left and then she came in
without her pants again to the right. What the is happening?
I think it's just Peggy. Is that his girlfriend? I'm sorry. I
don't know the this the most of the like CX or IP2 streamers.
I don't know most of their lore. So, if you're here from one
of their communities, I don't mean any disrespect. I just don't
actually follow that much. So, I'm covering it right now. Trying
to get as much as I can. Feel free to correct me. I'm not like
uh proud about this, okay? I don't I don't like being ignorant
most of the time. So, if I am wrong, just correct me.
She's some dumb [__] Okay. All right. All right.
I apologize to that person. I apologize. Yeah, Piggy is actually
pretty cool. She looks like a child's slave, but she does tattoos
and Okay. Okay. Okay. Listen, I take it back. I apologize to
that person. I'm just I'm mostly making jokes cuz he literally
we saw that girl come off on stream or on screen for a little
bit. And then I like laughed and I was like, "Oh, Sam's just
going to tell him to like go move to Manila and Filipino hookers
with him." And then he actually suggested that. Okay. So, so
the pieces fell into place and that's that's what I saw. I want
to make sure I know somebody for many years before I have kids
with them. Okay. You know, Kim, do you think it's a good idea
you guys have kids in a family? Really? After everything that
at this moment? No, of course not. Okay. One year ago, do you
think it was a good idea? Ty, tie tie tie. Listen, it says he's
in Manila. And if you expected me to see that girl in Manila
and I don't know I know nothing about her and then think she's
uh what do you call it? Thai instead of Filipino, you're crazy.
I don't think there's been a moment in your relationship that
I know of where I would have asked you and you would have been
like yes, now's a good time.
You know, you know, bro, come on, bro. Come on. We'll go we'll
go a few months and I'm like, yeah, you know, yeah, I do want
to marry this person and I would want to have kids with this
person. And then we'll run into a situation like last night where
she needs to step up and be a girlfriend and she fails. But it's
like that's what's hard. It's like we'll go I'm trying to decide
whether this is Ice Poseidon's insecurity or is it his insecurity
or is it that she was like like people were talking about him
and he wasn't defending or she his girlfriend wasn't defending
him at all. Which one was it? cuz uh I would like to know if
there are like screenshots or sorry if there are clips of people
talking him specifically and her like not saying anything or
laughing along with them cuz I do think that's kind of up if
you have like a partner even if you're mad at them about something
right but yeah that's the problem is all the clips we saw just
made it look like insecurities every day everything's good we're
having a good time everything's fun but she fails at the basic
necessities that a man would Okay somebody said clip of Kimmy
clip of Kimmy taking the side. It looks like you were trying
to It was me. You It looked like it was me that would touch me,
but it wasn't.
But it wasn't. Were you? I feel like you were not trying to touch
me. You would never do that. No. [__] I never even
looked at or looked at you like
don't don't know. Mike is like Mike is do not with my Do not
[__] with my KCIP. Do not [__] with my
connections. I don't know you. I don't know you, Kimmy. Off.
Get the out of here, Kimmy. No, don't look. Kimmy, don't be weird
cuz you know I like that. I feel that way, but the clip everyone
is upset because it's not like that. They're looking at the wrong
person. I know you're with I would never do no weird. Okay.
I would never do no. Okay. All right. That doesn't sound like
she's defending the guy.
That That doesn't sound like she's defending the guy. I get how
if you're insecure, it feels like that.
and yeah, not having any physical intimacy that could make you
insecure. I can see how he's hearing it that way. But I don't
think uh I think that's her trying to assuage his like insecurity,
right? That's what she's trying to do there. But because she's
like forcing this guy to say it, it's also going to come off
as like she is hiding something to Ice Boseidon when he's like
super insecure and and not in a good place. They are also afraid
of Ice Boseidon. It's very funny. And you see the clip they're
talking about. We already showed it just a little while ago.
It was uh it was this one. Hold on. It was the one where they
go into the room. Was it this one?
Yeah. Why' you do that? I would say that you come to Joelle and
be like, "Oh, you're an Asian viewer." That was rude. That was
rude. So, okay. I'm going to the pool. I'm going to the pool
and I'm going by myself and I'm on mushrooms. Wait, was that
the Was that the problem?
Wait, the problem.
Was that was
[__] everything, Paul. That's what you do. Good job.
Good job.
It wasn't that clip. Sorry. That clip was funny though. Hold
on. Is the clip when Shuy's walking in? We watched it earlier.
The one where uh it looks like this guy might be trying to like
touch her or she might be trying to touch him. It's uh Is it
this one?
It's this one. This is the clip.
I think this is the clip we're talking about here. Okay. There
that one. And then there was uh there's one more. There's one
more. Was it this one? I'm trying to get her to open up. Jimmy
is in here. No, Hannah's Nobody's in there. That's my room. Nobody's
in there. It was It's like one of these clips are like what's
making him insecure. Okay. It's like one of them. Uh back to
back to the ice beside Sam such as defending him or being intimate
and affectionate
or listening to his feelings when he's feeling. Kimmy's on the
bed in that clip. Upset where he fell onto the bed. Oh, Kimmy's
not the girl on the left. Dude, what am I doing? Sorry. I really
I really don't recognize her. Hold on. Watch that clip again.
So Kimmy's over here on the right. Then I thought this was Kimmy
here with just the blonde hair. You got to zoom in.
Oh, I see. Incriminating.
Okay. No, I I is losing his mind. Ice is losing his mind on that
one. That's
That's really really not anything. Okay.
That's I thought I thought like maybe it was this girl who like
touches him. I thought it was this girl like touching this guy's
like
uh it looks like she could be touching something, right? Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. This is like I thought I thought Kimmy was the girl
on the left here. I didn't realize that was hand on the
He falls over. She pushes him away. She stands up and moves away
like
Brh.
Brh. Oh, Ice is in a bad spot. Ice is in a bad spot. I don't
get upset super often, so she doesn't really have to do that
much. And the whole thing like, you know, I try to be understanding
and like, yeah, you know, if you don't want to have whatever,
but I'm not, you know. Okay. Okay. Hold on. One more one more
angle on this same
Oh, it looked like this guy himself.
What is this?
Don't get close to me. Oh, does does the other girl push him?
Open up. Hold on. Wait, wait, wait, wait. Not this one. That's
not this one. Does uh does Hannah push him?
No, it looked like Hannah pushed him from from this angle. Looked
like Hannah pushed him. You see how he like kind of like jolts
forward a little bit. Oh, weird.
This is incriminating, Tanner. What is this? But yeah, he literally
just It looks like he himself and and he's like grossing people
out with it. Yeah, I probably only saw that angle and got autistic,
I guess. So, it comes to a point where enough's enough, but besides
that, I mean, you know, it's pretty pretty normal. That's rough,
dude. The fact that you want to have a family and you want to
do this before you're 35. I don't think that's a good reason
to keep trying to work this out. I think you can I think you
can just go on with your life and it you will just come across
someone who just matches you better. You're you're you're you're
trying to fix something that just you've tried and you've tried
and you've tried and you've tried and you've tried. Like it makes
no sense. It makes no sense. It doesn't. And I know I I I know
Kim deep down could admit that, too. But she likes it. She's
comfortable. It's great for her, bro. It's great for her because
she knows you're ready to marry her and impregnate her whenever
she wants that. She knows that there's money there. She knows
there's security. She knows that you have like the fame and the
stuff that helps her out with whatever she wants to do. It's
all perfect for her. You know, I think you know what bo You know
what makes it real hard for me to to even consider, you know,
finding someone else is the fact is is the fact that every time
we fight, she can she just says, "I just find a new guy. I can
find someone new in in days." And she's right. You know, I mean,
she's a girl. Yes, of course she can find someone to her, but
she's not she's not, you know what I mean? Sure. I mean, sure.
Go find that person.
Bro, Sam Pepper just sitting here feeding constant like red pill
talking points to ice is very gives to me. That's what I don't
like. I don't like when she says, "Yeah, I'll just find somebody
new in a couple days." Or, especially, okay, this is especially
funny from Sam Pepper because if I'm not missing my guess, does
this guy even around or does this guy say this and then only
have serial monogous
Is that what Sam's doing right now where he's like, "Hey buddy,
you have you are a high value man. You need to play the field,
play your options." And then he sits there only having stable,
monogous relationships.
Is that what Sam does? Is that who Sam is as a guy? He's gonna
give the opposite of what he does as advice. Is Sam wrong here?
Yeah. Basically,
telling Ice to find somebody who he doesn't connect with on any
level except he could get right with a prostitute is not good
advice. It's not good advice at all. You know, whatever she says,
she's allowed to find someone new. Cuz I'm not going to be able
to find someone new super fast because I'm not looking for just
like I'm I don't want to just random hoes. Like I'm looking for.
She's saying like if she's not going to find ice,
you know how hard she is to deal with as well. You know all of
her problems more than anyone. You know them. Yeah. You know,
yes, she can find someone to put a inside her. Any girl can find
someone to put a dick inside her. And you can turn around and
you can find a girl to come around and you you know that too.
It's no different,
bro. Is she saying that to her? say, "Go find that. You're not
going to find anyone that offers you what I offer you and actually
cares about you from the ground up. From nothing. From the ground
up." I mean, well, she she always she always tells me that she
can find people who are richer than me and and and nicer than
me. So then go find them. I'm sorry, bro. If a girl says that
to me, go find them. That's what I'm going to say. I'm so sorry.
There's no way a girl's saying that to me. There's no way.
Everybody says this and then you're in a relationship with somebody
you actually care about and they say some like that to you and
it like hurts and you don't want it to be the like like I everybody
understands where I is coming from where like oh they've got
problems, right? I'm sorry. Yeah, his girlfriend might say that
when they're fighting, but I just Nobody's That's not how real
relationships work. You just like, oh, you said something mean.
I'm out forever. Bye. Then go find them.
I I say I don't think you'll be able to find somebody who is
richer than me or even has the same money as me because
um
you know they're not going to want to deal with like there's
like she's, you know, she's a lot to handle. She's a lot to deal
with. She's high maintenance. That's what she wants. Paul, if
that's all she cares about, if that's all she cares about is
that they have money and now put up with her, then that's criminal,
bro. Does she Is that all she cares about? Or is that what Paul
like cares about? Is that like is that what he's saying? Like
you'll never find somebody like me who makes this much money.
Is that how he says it or is that how she says it? I don't know.
Right. It could be either way here.
He could easily in a fight say you'll never find somebody like
me with this much money who like cares about you this much. Right?
Because it yes it does sound to me Kokina Kiana whatever your
name is. Okay. Kokina.
Okay. It sounds to me like that's what he talks about. Right.
You'll never find somebody like me who makes this kind of money.
Yeah. Of course she's going to say it back.
But Noel she she only says the money thing because I bring up
the money thing. She she says what she wants a guy who's nicer
than me. Um yeah. Oh. Oh, pause champ right there. Noel, she
she only says the money thing because I bring up the money thing.
She Dude, why are people People are so easy to read. People are
so easy like I could just We all see it. I don't even think I'm
doing something special here. We just We all know. She wants
a guy who's nicer than me. Um and then I'm like And then I'm
like, "Yeah, what?" You know, not I'm not even I'm basically
pulling up like a like a child's coloring book and barely staying
within the lines. Okay, I'm not doing something special here.
We can all see this. You have a lot for you here. And she's like,
"Well, I can find a guy with money, too." It's like I don't know.
She said she thinks I'm like super mean and super like [__]
up towards her, but she doesn't understand that I'm mean because
she makes me feel insecure.
Like it it's a spiral. Yes. This is tremendous tremendous amounts
of uh what would you call it? Introspection from Ice Poseidon
here. Like actually unheard of amounts of introspection from
Ice Boseidon for him to say this. Okay, this is probably the
thing. There's like a lot of a lot of behaviors I've heard about
Ice Poseidon in the background that you wouldn't expect. The
one I I bring up is that I've heard he's like one of the most
punctual people. Like he doesn't leave people hanging. If he
tells you he's going to be somewhere, he'll be there. He will
be there on time. Right. So, when like when events when he's
like booked in to go to an event, unless he's like canceling
beforehand, if he says he'll be there at a time, he's like there,
he shows up on time, right? Um, and that's another one where
it's like, okay, he's willing to admit I hurt her. Not a lot
of like narcissistic streamer types can even admit that they
can't, right? That is actually something most people cannot admit
at all. I'm not joking. You think you think this is like I'm
being crazy. This is like actually difficult for most people.
I realize that we're I I'm describing a normal human behavior
here. Okay. Ice is always late. Oh, well, I've only seen him
go to like kick or keep and maybe if he's got to be somewhere
in person. Sorry. I had uh what? Destiny and Kelly Jean both
said this about him. I was like, "Oh, it seems like uh expected.
Not with stream. He's extremely not with stream. He's extremely
unreliable." Okay. I just know two people who know him like personally
or I knew two people at least who knew him personally who said
this about him. So, that's my bad if that's not the case. But
I those are the only two people I knew with personal experience
with him and they're like, "Oh, he's always on time if we like
book something with him."
Crazy. Okay. Okay. But it seems like people who do watch him
are like, "No, no, no. That's not the case. Never mind then.
Never mind."
The more insecure, she'll make me feel insecure. She'll make
me feel like
long periods of time and then I'll and then I'll crash out, be
mean, and then she'll say I'm I'm a mean person. But you also
know you know how it works, Paul. You're like the, you know,
you're like the top of this of all the CX.
You're the leader. You know that how it works is that like when
you show them insecurities, it gives that other person the power.
You know what I mean? It puts her on top. Every time she does
that and she makes you insecure and then you show you're insecure.
She then gets the power
She becomes the leader of your relationship and then she just
gets to toy with you.
Uh, Kelly does still come on stream. Yeah, Kelly is still around.
And then and then that's why that's why your relationship's right
now because you lost all the power in it and she knows that you're
going to take her back again. Like I'm saying, she knows you're
going to Guys, if you like the content, okay, I want you to keep
the content flowing. Okay, we are an hour left on the stream
right now. I am going to chill again. Guys, if you like the content,
I really appreciate you being here. Follow me on Twitter, x.com/jastk
with an underscore Twitter or sorry, twitch.tv/jast. TV/JSDK
with an underscore. Follow on both platforms. Join the Discord.
discord.gg/jdlk.
All right. If you guys want to make the content go longer, you
can do so. You can sub on kick. You can sub individually. You
can gift subs on kick. Okay. You can donate through Streamlabs
or Kickbot. Either one. $2 TTS through Kickbot, $3 TTS through
Streamlabs. All right, guys. Uh and you know, if you want to
donate in any other way, okay, there's Patreon. patreon.com/jok.
If you're in the Discord, there's extra perks in the Discord.
You get to talk during the like timeouts at the beginning of
the stream. You get to do a whole bunch of stuff. All right,
but there's multiple roles. You get multiple perks. Pre-stream
post stream content starting at the Oiler tier. All right, guys.
Sign up for the sign up for the Patreon. patreon.com/j. Go sign
up for the free tier if you if you need. Okay, if you're not
signed up for the free tier, sign up for the free tier. People
gift memberships sometimes, okay? Get on the Patreon. patreon.com/jok.
It's awesome. It's cool. Anyway, we continue on. We continue
on. Spruce Willis, thank you very much for the gifted sub. I
appreciate it, buddy. Going to take her back. She knows that
you're ready to like let everything go. Even after writing all
of that out. It's crazy that you're going to take her back and
you will. And then she'll just do even more. She's like, "Wow,
I got away with sending guys pictures. I got away with not him.
I got away with not kissing him. I got away with defending everyone
else. I got away with this. I got away with this. What could
I get away with next?
You know,
she has a like she has a free pass for anything. You feel
she's not It's just hard because I don't think she has bad intentions,
you know? I think it's just I think she's just toxic. Yeah, it's
not bad intentions, but she's taken full advantage of the situation.
I mean, I would, bro. I agree. I agree. I think she takes advantage
of me. I I think she
um you know uses my emotions against me, takes advantage of me,
fight you know like she goes against like she makes me insecure
on purpose like yeah I know like if if Kimmy was you right and
you could do she calls me she calls me she calls me a sociopath
every single day almost.
She's she just will randomly bring up I think you're a sociopath
or I think you're a narcissist. And I'm like, well, I mean, that's
crazy that you think that because uh I just had a 3-hour conversation
with you, confiding in your feelings and then and then she called
me a narcissist after that 3-hour conversation. And it's just
like more attempts at bringing me down. Okay, hold on. Need to
go to another clip. Another clip from Kicker. Believe it or not,
I'm very attractive. Um, you should know that. Keep telling yourself
that. Keep telling yourself. Keep telling yourself that. I mean,
you should know. What does that mean?
What? It means Mau tried to me by the way.
You were asking me.
You shock me. What did I say to you?
You look.
Okay. All right. All right.
Like I said, somebody made a comment about Malik earlier. That's
apparently the context. All right. We got the context now. Three
hours getting this. I'm getting some water. Just give me a second.
Break up with me because I uh complained about sitting in traffic
for 1 hour. So, I don't know. You know, I don't think that makes
me a narcissist, but it's just like an attempt at breaking me
down. I think you care about also the wrong things sometimes.
Sometimes you say things and I'm like, there's no way that's
what you care about right now. when there's all of this other
stuff that's just such red flags and it feels like you're willing
to let a lot of the other red flags go if she just like tells
you you're great and you and says that she loves you and that
you're hot. Like literally, I feel like if Kimmy comes and she
says to you like, "Bro, like I'm so sorry. I know I don't say
you're hot enough, but you're like the hottest guy I know and
like I'm turned on and I want to you right now." Then you're
going to be like, "All right, let's get back together." You know,
like I'm telling you, like you you you're clinging on to the
wrong the wrong importance. I in the way you write. I only can
see what you write, but in the way you write and the things you
say, you're clinging on to things that aren't. And she's done
that to you, bro. She's made you need that. She's made you need
that by not giving it to you. She's starved you. But now you're
so thirsty that you're willing to let everything go just to have
that that her feed you that a little bit like to feed you, bro.
She's punishing you with love. That's when that's the definition
of a toxic relationship. She's punishing you with love.
That's I mean
Yeah. I don't know. I mean, if she doesn't me every single day,
uh,
you know, here on out, then that's
her. There's a million girls you can put your inside.
Who cares,
bro? There's so many girls that are hot that will you, Paul.
I'm just I'm telling you. Oh, I know. I had like four girls message
me today, but I just blocked them. What is wrong with you, bro?
Oh my god. Please. Please.
Please, Paul. Please. You're going to be so sad.
You're going to be so sad again. I don't uh I don't talk I don't
want to talk to other women unless uh unless I'm, you know, we're
full. We're broken up. So, yeah, I know that. I know that, but
I'm just saying it's Yeah. I mean, there's no point. It doesn't
matter. I There's no point me trying to tell you what to do or
not what to do. You need to make your own decision. But you're
going to be sad. You're going to be sad.
It's just like it's like if you're on stake and you're playing
a slot and every single time you played this slot, it's giving
you nothing and you keep trying. You're like, "No, if I try it
this time, it's going to work. If I try it this time, it's going
to work. If I try it this time, it's going." There's no way you're
going back to that slot after the 10 times of playing it, 20
times of playing it. You know, it never pays. So, stop giving
it your money.
This is by far maybe the worst comparison he could have done.
I have no idea. Brett, these guys are brain. Really? You know,
yeah, but you know what? You know what they say, Sam?
He's just going to say some
that slot is
Godamn it. Sam, why would you do that?
Why Why would you do that? Why would you do that? Why would you
do that? Why would you do that?
Oh, bro. I hope it is for your sake, bro. I hope it is. Just
like come on. Like the gun, the [__] whatever. Like,
even if there's no way in your mind that you're actually going
to That's crazy. Yeah. No. If I didn't take three Xanax yesterday,
I probably would have shot myself in the face. Yes. Come on.
Like, you know that's enough. You know that's enough.
I took three Xanax in the car and then I was like, well, I'm
just going to shoot myself because uh I feel like come on. But
then the Xanax kicked in and I started feeling really good. So,
I just kind of sat there and uh contemplated for like an hour
and then I just went home. But like that's that's crazy, you
know? You should never let anyone have that power over you. It's
And what's crazy is it's you. And I know you you're a little
power hungry
and you the fact that you let someone have that level of power
over your life for me is shocking. It's shocking. Yeah. I I I
like having I like having power uh Sam, but I don't want to have
power over my person I'm in a relationship. No, you don't. It's
not about you having power over her. It's the fact that she has
full power over you. She has the power to make you want to yourself
like that to end your life. The ultimate power like the ultimate
power, you know, there's nothing above that. It's you gone forever.
Yeah. Not like just being vulnerable in a relationship, unfortunately.
And that like
that it sucks, but that's like kind of what it is unfortunately.
Like that's not good. That's not good that you have someone doing
that. I I think
you know in most romance stories that is generally what that
means that like if that you love somebody like so much that if
they don't want to be with you that's like making you not want
to live anymore. I thought that was like that's broadly what
they talk about. Okay. In like songs and kind of relationships
are you talking about? I mean I'm sorry that's like literally
what Okay. I don't know. I I keep forgetting I keep forgetting
that uh it's like a pretty big incel crowd here. Never mind.
There's
definitely not my first option.
Stop. Really stop. You remember when you had to send someone
to get the guns
because of Kimmy? Come on. Come on. Yeah. I'm just I'm just trolling.
Don't worry.
Oh, yeah.
Everyone's Everyone's laughing. All right. Well, you know, I
got to go. I have uh stuff to do. But really, be careful, honestly.
And I mean if you want to talk about private stuff, you can anytime.
You're getting automoded. Scum fiend. No, no, no, no, no. That's
not what it is. It's the whole point is like you if you love
somebody, if you like Yeah. If you're if you're if you're like
loving somebody enough to marry them, that's usually like, oh,
if they're leaving like I'm lost. I feel like you don't actually
do it, but you think about it, right? I'm here. But just be careful.
Please don't let someone have so much power over you. Yeah, I
have a lot to think about. All right. Love you, bro. Bye. Bye.
Bye. Bye. All right. All right, that's it for the sand pepper
stuff. Okay, I think we switch over to the water park from
today. Was that today or was that yesterday? I actually don't
even remember now. Me. Okay, hold on. We're going back to the
water park stuff. Okay, I got two different bits here.
You literally said that I could d this [__] but not
take it. But you're a
So Shuy and Zena get into a fight at the water park. Okay, get
in a fight at the water park. You're literally a walking hypocrite.
So, you're still holding on to something. You're a hypocrite.
I mean, why would I not
about me? I don't care. I don't care. I don't care.
Earlier, you just really got to leave this toe up here the whole
time. Kind of gross. Now all of a sudden you don't want problem.
I was like, now it's fair use, guys. Now it's fair use. There's
a toe.
The only way that the only reason this doesn't work is cuz you
realize I don't give a what you think you have against me. You
can't use against me. I don't care. You said you have recording
the truth about everything against
this camera like you said.
Show a recording. Nobody recorded it. Nobody confirmed anything.
Nobody.
Is these the same things? Hold on. Where's the Okay, that's We
go back a little bit and it's maybe them arguing back here. It
looks like they argued for quite a while here. So, hold on. We'll
uh we'll keep going. What did I just I just Yeah. Thank you.
on your side like you think. You try to gain favor.
Go argue with your Yes, I am, bro. Cuz you're not keeping the
same energy.
Cool. Orange cubby cat though. Be really
I'm not taking care of that cat, by the way. What do you mean?
It's not my responsibility. They're going to watch her on the
boat. She's your cat. I need uh I need a I need something. Yeah,
he green. He green.
That cat does not look That cat does look like it's I decide
that I don't want it. Not well groomed. Okay. What's going on
here?
And then you're going to have another cat to take after. Okay.
What are we doing here that we're Jesus, I have no idea why I
had that. Thank you for the clip. This is a little crazy, but
damn. Okay, what else do we have here tonight?
Okay, we've got a couple things. We got the Piers Morgan episode
that is there. Okay, we got the Piers Morgan episode. We've got
what else? Oh, I've got Oh, I've got a couple things actually.
Bro, I was thinking um
dude, if you want to watch somebody just like virtue signal over
nothing. It's very funny, bro. We got to we got to start keeping
up with Teone again. Okay, I think we got to start keeping up
with Teone because Teone keeps saying and doing ridiculous things.
Absolutely ridiculous things.
God, he did like a stream on Lewig recently. It was uh it was
super goofy. He did a segment on Lewig and then I think he started
talking about his ban again with Asmin Gold. Him and Asmin Gold
been going back and forth over and over again. Very weird. Souvenir
SC, thank you for the 10 months, buddy. 10 10 months resub. Let's
go. Thank you. Thank you.
We do love techie. Um h me see here. I got to look around and
see what we're doing. What are we doing? What are we doing? Will
this guy respond to my question? Maybe.
Bro, the people how
man like uh sorry I I was like looking at this guy like argued
with me on Twitter. I don't This guy just doesn't understand
anything.
He's he's like telling me okay Pisco is not correct about this.
I say Pisco is correct about his opinions on this. Pisco is not
correct about this. Every copyright lawyer has spoken out as
that has spoken out has said Ethan has a case. Yeah, Pisco says
Ethan has a case. What are we doing here?
The word bias comes to mind among other words. So, I can only
wonder why you of all people choose to side with the seemingly
the only content creator lawyer that you agree with. What? Oh,
I didn't even notice how [__] this this comment was
formulated in the first place, but okay. You just don't understand
that Pisco's belief is that Ethan is a strong case. Yes.
He says, "Oh, so you either either you misspoke when you said
dissenting opinion meaning something different than your use
of the word or you said nothing worthwhile to consider
or like or as another option.
as another option here
uh perhaps it's not about whether or not the case is strong.
It's something else, right?
Can can I not say somebody has like a case and then also say
but I disagree with some something else they've said. And this
guy says, "Don't be obtuse. Pisco has been the only lawyer content
creator who's spoken out on the lawsuit in opposition to the
merits of Ethan's case. I don't know that he's done this. I don't
think he's ever done this. Nobody's doing this. Like this guy
is just this guy is just hallucinating. No, no, no. Pisco managed
to get everybody to respond to this, right? Without actually
understanding what his position is or what anyone else's position
is. It's so amazing. Uh if you're just trolling in chat, I can
just get you out. you can just go. Like literally nobody understands
at all what Pisco is saying. It's like so weird to me that all
of these people are
they just have no idea what they're talking about. How how how
are there so many people that are like brain damaged on this?
It's actually baffling. So many people in my own Discord who
actually just don't understand anything going on here who will
argue without understanding anything. They'll just go, "Wait,
wait, wait. Did you say Ethan's not 100% correct on everything?
Oh my god. You're Why are you sir who's on stick? Why are you
doing that? That's like That's literally all that happens. It's
amazing. Pisco is expressing that people are wrong on copyright
and you're also invested in a case built on a wrong premise which
is ironic. Implying that uh apparently the Destiny case that's
not on a wrong premise. He literally admitted to doing the thing
he's being sued for completely. Yeah. I don't I don't understand
where these people come from. I just I don't get it. I don't
get how there are so many people who are just like completely
It's baffling.
It's actually baffling. It's It's enough to make me just not
want to be on the internet at all that like literally nobody
who operates on the internet in any way
operates in like any form of good faith or anything approaching
good faith like ever.
It's so boring.
It's so what's the point of having conversations with people
if they like can't identify what is true and false in the world
in any way? They just have to listen to somebody else tell them
what's true and false.
It's bizarre. Wait, was that Far? Yeah, Farro was on Pierce today.
So, I'm thinking about doing that for the next uh I don't know
10 15 minutes or something. Oh, what is this? Hold on. More leaked
DMs from Kimmy. Hold on. These are more leaked DMs from Ice like
6 minutes ago. Okay, hold on. She brought it up and I told her
how I told you not that you're not invited and she felt bad and
doesn't want you to I don't know if any of this is cool. This
is like um you really do ruin things and make everything about
you. I was so excited to go for my to Miami for Hannah's birthday
and now I'm dreading it. This whole week was about you and it
is continued. I won't go. It's fine. I assume this is in the
right order. You don't even remember or say what you say or care.
And dating someone that my friends have to worry if they were
going to ruin social events sucks. You can't handle someone else
having attention. You ruined Dream Hack. Now you want to ruin
Miami. You couldn't be more wrong. He says back. Kimmy continues.
I won't make the mistake of not having before leaving even if
I wait around and want to and you don't come because you're too
tired or because people are surround
and that makes me uncomfortable or if we are fighting and you
are mean and I don't want to. I understand now I'm forced to
have sex with you under any condition and if not you will ruin
any event or time I have away from you. The world revolves around
you and I understand that now. Every morning when I wake up my
first thought will be have I pleased my master today
dude. Okay. Okay. So, Kimmy's quite upset. Okay. This is such
a toxic ass way to put it. You really don't give a about how
insecure you've made me with this statement. We've had one time
since April. I'm asking for anything. Like, I'm not being an
[__] Like, you never want to have with me or seduce
me or and you actively deny me when I attempt. Don't try to make
it so I'm forcing you to me when I'm ask when I'm being an [__]
I'm asking you for to do it any for you to do it anytime at all.
I guess he just leaked all of their DMs before she went to Miami
for Hannah's birthday. Uh, you win. I don't know what else to
do. Still can't sleep. I told you what to do. You always pick
everyone else over me. Paul, I picked you and you embarrass me
publicly. You made a joke of me on Discord. You attacked my friends.
It's Hannah's birthday and you're attacking her. She did nothing
to you. Ice leaked DMs from Kimmy. Uh, it seems like that's Yeah,
I don't know why he's leaking these. I Man, this is like It's
such a common thing for people to like lose their over stuff
like like for people for relationships to fall apart that way.
It's like such a common thing. It's kind of crazy. Okay, what
do we got? We got 16 minutes. How far could we get through this?
I didn't see Farro was on here for this panel. So, this is what
the death to the IDF thing that we had going on.
Where was this at? A was this a concert in California or something?
Glastenbury has made headlines far removed from the festival's
usual message. Glastenbury.
Where's Glastenbury
Festival? Where does this happen? Bob Villain faces UK criminal
investigation for saying this. Okay, it's in the UK. I saw the
clip of Hassan laughing at this and everybody's like, "Oh my
god, can you believe Hassan laughed at this?" Yeah, I I can I
can totally believe Hassan laughed at this. Death. Death to the
IDF. Death. Death to the IDF. Death. Death to the IDF. Didn't
say death to Israelis. They said death to the IDF. Again, you
are Israelis. I I would just say like
I'm sorry if if some random people were like death to unfortunately
that is how that is how pro Palestinian people see the IDF. Okay.
They see them as like relatively equivalent to kind of a you
but that is what they think. That is what they think. Was that
Dollar Tree Hassan?
Oh, who's the person you're thinking of? I just saw Taylor.
I don't know who this is. This is Taylor Loren's. This woman
was uh I think she's pro-Israel. No, no, no. She was the She
was the one who when Hassan was on before, she was on Hassan's
side and she but she made Hassan's points way better than him.
If I remember this black lady correctly. Remember? Yeah. Everybody
here said he's real nice. Another
one. What the [__]
Did somebody just appear?
Oh, there's like a dead air filter and it jumps forward. Yeah.
What the? That guy just teleported in. One crash trying to catch
out earlier.
Why don't I see your phone? What do you need to see on my phone?
I want to open our text. I don't have my phone. Why do you want
to open our text? Cuz I want to open it. Why? All right.
Oh, hell no.
My fault. You just lost all respect I had for you and I no longer
want peace. You talk disgusting about me behind my back again
to another random chatter and I can't trust you.
What are you doing? Peace, by the way. But what did she just
tell me 2 minutes ago? Chat, what did she just tell me 2 minutes
ago? She said she wanted peace. Right. Right. Or am I tripping?
I'm leaking whatever I want. I don't give a [__]
about your fake lies and not wanting to lose me because you sure
made the actions to lose. This is what she says, but then she
tries to act like I'm the one starting right now, right,
bro? Make a make a wish. Going off the rails, okay? Giving these
these kids are like, I want I want a super thick Miami stripper
for a girlfriend for a couple months, guys. My last couple months.
And then just give this Make a Wish kid what he wants. That's
crazy. What are they doing over there?
It's wild stuff. You're just going to stare at the camera now.
Okay.
Might be I think your bald head, no eyebrows, and yellow teeth
might be throwing her off. Just an observation. Brush teeth next
time, bud. Off. Just an observation. Brush teeth next time, bud.
Look at the top of his head. Realize I'm pressing you back. I'm
making this everybody's thing. Lazy river. You take it back.
Lazy river. Lazy river.
Yes, I take it back. You take it back cuz you realize it's not
going to go your way, bro. What do you mean? So do
What? You're both cracking out. I'm not even trying to crash
out. It's just annoying. I want you to crash out. I want you.
Yeah, I want you to air everything out. Cuz I want to be done.
Be done with what? You are the one that just said that. Why are
you smiling? This is what I don't like about you. You're actually
smiling right now, son. You're laughing and smiling like you're
so annoying, dude. You're absolutely annoying. You're like, "How
far can I push her? Can I actually make her leak? Can I actually
make her crash?" You said you're going to do it. You said you're
going to do it, so I want you to, bro. No, I'm not going to.
Yeah, cuz you can't blackmail me. You can't hold my head. Well,
not blackmail, but you can't hold above my head. I'm not holding
over your head, but you can't keep trying to paint in a script
and switching up and then Sorry, the comment about him looking
like the Prometheus guy. Hold on. Like the Prometheus uh what
is it? Originator race or whatever. Prometheus.
What is the Prometheus like alien race? He does kind of look
like the Prometheus looking engineers. He looks like one of the
engineers.
It's like the same guy. What the Hold on. Yeah, it's like the
same guy. That's the same. These guy These guys are related.
Okay, that's crazy. Sorry.
Let me go back.
You said you're going to do it, so I want you to, bro. My head.
Well, not blackmail, but you can't hold [__] above
my head. about holding [__] over your head, but you
can't keep trying to paint a narrative in a script and switching
up and then apologize about it later. Like the you said before,
maybe she has feelings for me because she gave me a laugh. You
know that Adriana's top lip. Okay. Well, listen, mine was better.
I don't know what Prometheus and Bob even is. But I do know that
the alien, the engineers from Prometheus, that's what he looks
like to me. You know, there's more context to that as well. So
why would
what you wanted to paint your narrative? I'm just saying what
more context. Why don't we both just start leaking back and forth?
I say something, then you say something. What are you saying,
bro? No, you're corny. You're cringe. Why you said no? Cuz you're
corny, bro. Okay, but we're not doing that, right? You said you
wanted some help. Mike Smalls and Woody are the most normal people
in this water park. Everybody knows me. I go live and I expose
what I did. You said it's going to be an exposing stream. You're
not exposing. Clearly, because I'm having fun at a water park
with my friend. Oh, now you're having fun. Okay. Yeah, cuz you
realize it's not sweet like that. In your Discord, you said,
"Oh my god, at some point here, this does blow up." Okay, this
is worth it. We just need to keep going. Going to be a leaking
stream, guys. I'm so excited. Are you ready? I say that. Why
don't you say I don't want to? Cuz it's not going to go your
way. What did I say? What did I say? What did I say? And what
did I say? You want me to get distracted about who's Yeah, I
do. I know you do. But you won't do it cuz you know you're not
in a good position, bro. Talk about you getting beat up. Well,
you want to talk about me getting beat up? Cuz that's not what
you said when you want to when you want to gas me up. When you
want to gas me upg
even if I don't when you want to gas me up is oh my god, you
were going crazy. You were going in and now it's you got [__]
You can't defend yourself. So what is it? You know why? Cuz it
makes you Your words are meaningless. No, it doesn't make me
mad. Your words are meaningless. You look bad. You go back and
forth on whatever you say just to try to make someone mad or
happy. They're meaningless words. I will say Shiv is a major
downgrade in just talking. Okay. Like Zena isn't even going hard
on him now cuz it's just like dude this guy's like kind of this
guy can't really form thoughts. How can I be mad? It's like it's
like for example when you're with someone and they say yo your
is so big it's so you break up and
you have a small tiny and you are always ugly like no you're
with me. I never said my ex had a small ever. He had a big and
I never ever said he had a small I've always been honest. You're
the one who just was talking about it. All right. Well I didn't
say this is the content now. Yeah. Yeah. We arguing. We arguing.
Yeah. Obviously, he got a he got a she can't get it wrong on
W. That's what they saying. He got a W chat. Yeah, I guess. So,
he'd be apologizing after he rude as [__] but as
soon as he turned off the stream, he back to apologize and say
he don't want to lose me. Saying he values me and my friendship
and he want me in his life. But if No, no, no. We friends, but
it's like you talking,
but he talking about me behind my back. He just admitted to
No, no, no. But are y'all? Yeah, we actually are. Want to know
the truth? Yeah, we all Yes, we've been [__] But
we don't want nothing serious, but we don't want nothing. Yes,
he let me
Zena is Zena is code switching here a little bit. Okay, Zena
is code switching pretty hard. He put me
That's a That's a pretty crazy thing to leak. She's lying. She's
probably lying. Yes. But
that's a pretty crazy thing to
Wait, it's a clip. Oh, she just said she No, she just said she
No, it's a clip. It's literally a clip. It's a clip. Girl, you're
literally so weird. You're a [__] I made something
up. I said I picked I don't care. I don't care. You're a
Oh
boy. What a weak. Yeah, you're definitely the bigger person.
You're bigger than me. You're the bigger person. You're definitely
the bigger person than me. I mean, you're I'm more mature than
you and I'm 10 years younger. Smaller than me. I'm 10 years younger
and more mature than you. You're a [__] child. Got
That's a meme in Chibi's chat for the rest of time now. Oh boy.
I said I want the problems. You did this. You turned the whole
string into an
Why you laughing? Why do you think that [__] funny,
dude? Go away. Why do you think I I'll stop that little bubble?
Your bubble not going to go nowhere, bro. Stop. Nah. Your bubble
not going to go nowhere, buddy. You said you wanted proping
you prop. I'll never let go. Let go of my tube. Nah. Why are
you always trying to control me? Oh yeah. I'm trying to control
me. Says the one holding on to my tube.
Don't argue on the tubes. [__] up. Cena can't get
on her tube now. Go. You threaten me.
Can you get off my foot? I have a I have a boo boo. I have a
boo on my foot. Suck boo. Yeah, you you have a boo boo. Let go
of me. You're the one wrong, bro.
You're wrong, bro. Should be peg
peged. You're wrong. Should be peg. Yeah, this is a peg peg peg.
Oh, he's running. Oh, hell. He's running.
She's [__] catching up. Jesus, chat.
Okay. Can we Can we go? Oh.
Is this it? Cuz I got another time stamp. Oh, he finds his way
back to her. Oh, never mind. That's not Zena. Whoops. What the
hell? What the hell is Wait, who is that? That's not No, that's
definitely I thought maybe it was Murk for a second. It's not
Murka though. What the hell?
Did you find me? Oh, hell yes.
I never said drunk.
You're literally drunk. So now you're gonna say I'm drunk. You're
ready. Okay. No, no, no, no, no, no. You just try to I Wait,
what the [__] I don't I don't ever see I don't ever
see Zena this wasted. What the [__] That's weird.
I've I don't think I've ever seen Zena like this wasted before.
She's like actually slurring super hard out of nowhere. You're
trying to disqualify what I said.
She like walk away and take like four shots and come back. What
the [__] Yeah. I don't think
drinking at a water park seems like a bad idea. Uh
maybe if you're going to like a wave pool, if you're just chilling
in the water, drinking is awesome. I'm going to drink more. You're
so
That's just whatever, dude. Ruin your own reputation. I'm just
a messenger. Sean, you read horrible me.
We still
love me though. Yeah, that black guy from the locker rooms is
back.
Okay, hold on. Okay, we got one more one more bit from the VOD
here. Okay, a little bit later on in the stream. I want you to
crack out. I want you to wait. I want you to hear everything.
Wait. Oh, this is the same one. Hold on. No, this is the same
one, isn't it? No, this is the same one. Never mind. Never mind.
Never mind. This was the same one. This is a little bit longer
version of the same one.
Uh, after fighting, Zena apparently texted Darius. Can I say
something on stream? Why is Zena texted me? Wait, is this where
the hairline starts? Oh no.
Oh no. That's Why is he doing that? Snack, right? Does anyone
know why? There's May I say something or not?
Post your hairline. No. Nope. Little bro. Lol. Bro, you bald
shame every man you come across on stream. It wouldn't even be
it would wouldn't even be genuine for me to post my hairline
because the front of my hairline is quite good. It's the uh the
crown. Okay. Okay. I got that Dean Withers. All right. That's
That's like uh But I'm old, too. So, you'd never know. You'd
never know cuz I didn't know. But I literally went to the I went
to the barber and he was like, "Hey, you're uh you're thinning
back here, just so you know." The first time ever.
First time I was ever told that. It was so up. It was so up when
my barber said that to me. He was like, "Hey, you're like thinning
back here a little bit. Just so you know, like you should know
if you if you want to do something about it." I was like, "What
the what the what a horrible feeling, right?" Uh, no. Because
I have like long hair and it it really you can't see it. Well,
you can't you can't see it that much. Like if I have my hair
styled at all, but probably if I wanted to do the like treatment
or whatever, I would probably start it sometime soon. I don't
know if I care. Oh, sorry. We're back to Darius. Uh, so Zena
is taxing. Zena's not doing good. What is this?
Yeah, Zena is having a fight and she's been drinking.
Yeah, bro. I love it. All right,
I'll teach my words.
Is he going to throw up? That's what it looks like. Mine smells
like they wait in line going for a slide or what?
Oh, maybe she wasn't feeling drunk. Maybe she's actually just
pissed me. There's no way you're mad. I literally left it with
the lifeguards with Joel's battery.
Then I don't know why you're shaking your head. I can shake my
head. So I hope I didn't go. It's unbelievable. So I'm going
to shake. What is unbelievable? It's unbelievable. I watched
brush his teeth this morning. Yeah, I did. Thank you. You got
behind me. Thank you for verifying. I don't think I don't think
Zena is like an alcoholic. That would be weird. Zena doesn't
drink that often. Zena is like the person at all these parties
who's usually I think she's like usually sober
late. No, I was showering and then I brushed my teeth. Wyoming.
I walked and brushed my teeth for 20 minutes. Why are they talking
about your teeth? I don't know what happened. Nothing. She's
just replying to a child.
I don't know what that is say. What the [__] did
that say?
I can I know the beat, but it's not saying the right lyrics.
I love people. Okay. Okay. What?
I don't know.
It was NH, but it was like saying something about people. I love
people.
Yeah. Should we go down the green one or should we do the same
one?
You want to go down the green one or this one? Is that a troop
one? No, we down this one. It's more exciting than the green
one. The green one is the first one we went on. No, we didn't
go down the green one before. Yes, we This is the one we went
down the first time. Really? She's awake. I know the spark, bro.
I've been here. I've been here 10 years. The hell was that? I've
been to this park like 20 30 times and I know every ride. I know
every ride. All
Oh, yeah. But we went up. We went up that way. That's why I thought
it was
We need to get them black and white
Yeah, sure.
I invited them and y'all want to parkry.
Hungry hippos. Hry
for dinner.
dude. What the are these donations?
Have to fully end stream when it's at one. Okay,
all right. I think that's about it for the fights and stuff at
the water park, right? I think that's that's got to be close
to it. I think so. Let me uh let me make sure I'm not missing
anything else. I think I think that's like literally everything.
There's one other clip that got included. Just a little meme.
Let's see. Baby trapped. Okay.
What's his name? Peaches. Her name is [__] It's her
cat.
She need a little change. So sweet. She doesn't need a little
change. Imagine that little cat.
But you take the cat.
What? You take the cat. No, we have to
Why don't you just take the cat and raise it on the
You can have a boat cat. Yeah. And how would I get it to the
boat? You just put the cat on the plane.
Yeah. A phone is my